while Americans are divided over banning
assault weapons a new poll shows they
agree that more needs to be done to stop
gun violence
77 percent say Congress is not doing
enough to prevent mass shootings in the
US and 62 percent say President Trump is
not doing enough Margaret Brennan is at
the White House Margaret good morning
good morning well press secretary Sarah
Sanders says here at the White House
officials will take the next two weeks
to meet with students educators law
enforcement and governors to discuss
what can be done President Trump has
said no student or teacher should be in
danger in an American school dozens of
high school students called for action
on gun control even posing as corpses
outside the White House 16 year old
Whitney Bowen said words of comfort from
the president fell short something needs
to change and politicians have the power
to make that change on Friday the
president visited Parkland school
shooting victims but ignored questions
on gun control
White House officials later said he is
reviewing a bill sponsored by Republican
Senator John Cornyn of Texas it aims to
make the federal background check system
more effective by improving how federal
and state governments report offenses
including criminal records that could
prohibit people from buying a gun this
scourge a school shooting after school
shooting Connecticut Democrat Senator
Chris Murphy co-sponsored the bill but
he also cautioned that no one should
pretend this bill alone is an adequate
response to this epidemic keep your guns
one gun control law that President Trump
did enact was to overturn Obama era
regulation aimed at preventing mentally
ill persons from buying a gun we're
restoring the rule of law and protecting
our cherished Second Amendment Florida
Republican Senator Marco Rubio argued
further gun control is pointless since
there are already so many guns on
American streets that genies out of the
bottle the same argument is get rid of
all nuclear weapons we could but China
is not Russia is not now the NRA does
support the Cornyn Murphy
bill which does not expand background
checks nor does it ban any kind of
weapon which is one of the demands made
by the student organizers in parkland
that you heard Adriana Diaz speak with
John we should also mention that the
administration is still reviewing
whether or not to ban bump stocks that's
a device that the shooter in the Las
Vegas Massacre used to increase his rate
of fire
Margaret thanks you know one thing about
that polling is that even though people
want Congress to move there's been no
change in opinion about assault weapons
after this which is what those students
are calling for